تبادل الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الاتهامات بخرق هدنه من ثلاثه ايام كان
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطون بلينكن قد
اعلن توصل الطرفين لاتفاقا بشان الالتزام
بها وتندرج الخطوه الهشه ضمن مساء اقليميه
ودوليه لوقف القتال في البلاد صدرت عن دول
بينها اسرائيل التي اعلنت وزاره خارجيتها
عن وساطه لانهاء الاحتراق بين الجانبين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي فرص الهضنه
الامريكيه في التوحد في التحول الى اساس
لوقف مستدام للقتال في السودان وفي اي
سياق يمكن وضع الوساطه الاسرائيليه التي
تقول انها تسعى لتحقيق نفس الهدف كيف نقرا
تعامل واشنطن مع اعلان الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه طرح مبادره لانهاء الازمه في
السودان ودعوه تل ابيب قبل ايام لممارسه
ضغوط على طرفي القتال
لوقفه بينهما
الى اين تتطور مواقف واطراف الازمه
السودانيه في تعاملها مع هذه التحركات على
ضوء ما يصدر عنها من مواقف وما يحكمها من
حسابات داخليه واقليميه ودوليه
[موسيقى]
ازمه داميه لا يعلم على وجه اليقين من
اشعل الشراره الاولى وكيف يمكن لها ان
تنتهي في السودان تكافح هدنه الايام
الثلاثه التي اعلنت عنها الولايات المتحده
لتبقى قائمه رغم ما يتبادله طرفان نزاع من
اتهامات بخرقها منسق الاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كوربي قال
للجزيره ان الهدنه صامده في السودان الى
الان وانهم يواصلون مناشده البرهان
واحميتي الالتزام بها بدوره قال المتحدث
الاقليمي باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي لويسمي
غالب وينه للجزيره ان الهدنه لا تزال
قائمه وان الجهود الاوروبيه مستمره لوقف
القتال وبينما اشار وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني الى ان لندن ستواصل الضغط من
اجل الحفاظ على وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان دخلت اسرائيل على خط الوساطه بين
قيادتي طرفي القتال وزير الخارجيات
الاسرائي قال ان اسرائيل احرزت تقدما في
المحادثات مع جانبي الصراع وضفقهان ان تل
ابيب تقترح استضافه محادثات بين البرهان
واحمد وكان موقع اكسيوس قد اكد ان واشنطن
اطلعت على مقترحا اسرائيليا بشان الوساطه
في السودان واضف الموقع ان الاداره
الامريكيه دعت تل ابيب في وقت سابق
لممارسه ضغوط على طرفي الازمه لانهاء
القتال بينهما
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم عزمي عبد الرازق الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي وعبر الهاتف من الخرطوم حافظ كبير
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث بمركز
العربي في واشنطن ابدا معك سيد عزمي سيد
عزمي جون كربي منسق الاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القومي يقولوا للجزيره ان الهدنه
صامده هل الوقائع على الارض تؤكد كلامه
وعموما في مستوى الاوضاع الاجتماعيه الان
خلال هذا اليوم كانت هنالك حاله من الهدوء
في معظم المدن الخرطوم الخرطوم بحري ام
درمان الخرطوم كذلك جنوب الخرطوم الاوضاع
بدات تعود بشكل افضل من الاول نسبيا
الاسواق فتحت بعض طلمبات الوقود بدات تعمل
بشكل جزئي كذلك المتاجر بدات تفتح الناس
في الاطراف يمارسون حياتهم بشكل طبيعي ولا
اعتقد بان هذا الامر له علاقه بالهدنه
وانما هو محاول التكيف مع الاوضاع يعني
بعد مرور اكثر من عشره ايام على بدايه
القتال ولكن الهدنه هي يعني نحن دخلنا في
الهدنه الرابعه كل الهدن التي تم اختبارها
لم تصمد امام تجدد القتال ما بين الاطراف
القوات المسلحه السودانيه والدعم السريع
واضح تماما قوات الدعم السريع منفصله
تماما عن قيادته وبالتالي لا تتنزل لديها
التعليمات يعني القوات على الميدان وهي
قوات مشتته وفاق ده تماما لزمام السيطره
وبالتالي يعني ما في اي
هذه الهدنه عن سابقاتها سيد عزمي لانه
لا طبعا لن تختلف لانه
السير المعارك والحرق هي التي تفرض منطقها
الان على الارض في ظل الاستقطاب في ظل
حاله الاستفزاز في ظل التحشيد والتحشيد
المقابل الان قوات الدعم السريع في حاله
من الانهاك وهي مشتته في الاحياء السكنيه
وبالتالي ليست لديها تواصل مع قيادتها ولا
يمكن ان تلتزم بهدنه في ظل مخاوفها
وتحركها الهدنه تعني وقف العدائيات وقف
العدايات ايضا ما زال متعلقه بوقف التحرك
وقف التحشيش
من السيد حافظ على هذه النقطه بشكل عشوائي
داخل الاحياء سيد حافظ ما امكانيه ان
تتحول هذه الهدنه الى وقف دائما لاطلاق
النار
اعتقد ان الهدنه هذه المره تختلف اختلافا
كثيرا عن التعليقاتها هناك اراده حقيقيه
من قبل الاطراف التي اعترضنا والتي وافقت
عليها وكذلك هناك يعني وصلت
التي تتحرك كل يوم
شبرا واحدا من المناطق التي ستطرد عليها
نحن نتابع على صفحات الدعم السريع يعني
اخبار تؤكد من اطراق السودان تؤكد التزام
قوات هذه الهدنه وهو ما توكله حقائق
الواقع في اليوم الان عندما نذهب في
الخرطوم في اي مكان ميت طلاب الدعم السريع
الان يعني تقدم الخدمات بدلا عن القتال في
الايام السابقه يعني هناك اكثر من حادث
سرقه في مدينه الخرطوم التي اصبحت
خالق لكن هناك حمايه ان توصلها اخواني
المسلحه ولا حتى لغات الشرطه وبالتالي
تحولت قوات الدعم السريع التي يصفها ضيفه
لانها غير متصله بقيادتها
بعيدا عن تبادل الاتهامات والحديث عن من
يصمد ومن انهك هذه الهدنه وصفتها بانها
تختلف عن الهدن السابقه ما الذي يجعلها
تختلف
عندما
الامر للسودانيه
ولديهم يعني رغبه في وقت الحرب كلها
المدنيه
والعسكريه كذلك من الحركات المسلحه كلها
ترفض الحرف هناك في اقليل جدا
كانت
الماضيه خيار غير الانحلال العاصفه وغير
الاستسلام امام يعني الصمود الاسطوري الذي
تواجه به الان الطائرات والرصافيرات
مختلفه وبالتالي
ليس هناك حل غير الاختباء والاختفاء تماما
من نشر السياده السوداني بعد ان حزنت
يعني يعني كانت تعول عليها بتحقيق مصري
قادح الان
نحن يعني
فشل الادوات والخشنه
واتجاه نحو الادوات السياسيه من المبادرات
مختلفه من دول وكذلك مكونات سياسيه والدول
الاقليميه هذه
كلها تحدث يعني بلسان واحد وهو ان السودان
لا ينبغي ان ينزل نحو العنف وينبغي ان
يمضي نحو العمليه السياسيه
ليس هناك طريق الان بعد ان اغلق طريق
الحرم وبعد ان اغلق طريق
الذي
دخلت
الطريق الذي يعني امامها هو العوده لعمليه
السياسيه
والعسكري بصوره جذريه القوات المسلحه كذلك
في الدعم السرير وكذلك القوات الكفاح
المسلحه طيب اشرت الى عوامل داخليه ساعود
الى هذه العوامل وايضا عوامل الخارجيه
ولكن دعني اسمع من الدكتور خليل العناني
الدكتور خليل ان يعلن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بنفسه عن هدنه الايام الثلاثه
الهدنه الاخيره اي دلالات يحمل ذلك
انا اعتقد الامر متعلق بالبعد الانساني
بالاساس نحن ازاء حاله كارثيه في السودان
نقص في المواد الغذائيه وفي المواد الصحيه
على الاقل اكتر من 400 قتيل حتى هذه
اللحظه 4000 مصاب هناك حاله فر وكر هناك
ممر انساني من اجل اخراج العالقين هناك في
السودان محاولات لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
من خلال اماكن مختلفه سواء بورت السودان
او اماكن اخرى وبالتالي هناك محال فرد
هدنه انسانيه من الصعب الحديث في هذه
اللحظه على الاقل اننا ايذاء مبادره
سياسيه متماسكه وجاده من اجل اولا انهاء
القتال المستمر في السودان ثانيا معالجه
جزر الازمه اي مبادره تطرح هذا السياق في
حاجه الى مرثلاثه على الاقل الامر الاول
المتعلق بطرح سياسي من اجل معالجه اصل
الازمه وجذور الازمه نحن ازاء الصراع دمعه
على السلطه بنى طرفين حتى هذه اللحظه دخل
في اطار معادله صفريه ليس هناك مساحه وسط
الالتقاء بينهم على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه
الامر الثاني هو وجود ما يطلق عليه العصا
والجزره يعني هناك ان يكون في امكانيه
للضغط وادوات وان يبقى قيل هذه المبادره
كي تؤتي ثمارها وليس فقط بمجرد كلام على
الورق الامر الثاني متعلق بامكانيه وجود
نوع من الاجماع الاقليمي والدولي على هذه
المبادره حتى هذه اللحظه هناك الصراعات
داخل السودان هناك مصالح واجندات متصارعه
متضاربه بين قوى اقليميه ودوليه وبالتالي
اي محاوله للفرد هدنه سياسيه مش انسانيه
ام مبادره سياسيه مش انسانيه بنتكلم على
حاجه لوقت هي تنضج هذه المبادره حتى هذه
اللحظه هي محاوله فقط لوقف القتال محوال
الانتقال من يوم الى ثلاثه ايام قد يكون
اسبوع بعد ذلك
محاوله تثبيت الهدنه بشكل او باخر من
الصعب توقع ذلك في ظل ما نراه حاليا من
اختراق الغده من كلا الطرفين السيد لعناني
اشرت الى شروط نجاح اي هدنه ولكن ماذا عن
الدور الامريكي خاصه بعدما اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بنفسه عن هذه الهدنه
هل تطور على مدار الايام منذ 11 يوما منذ
ان بدات المواجهات
المقبله اذا استجاب الطرفين لهذه المساله
لكن بشكل او باخر حتى هذه اللحظه الان نحن
ازاء محاوله فقط
لانهاء المعادله الانسانيه داخل السودان
طيب سيد العناني وانت تتحدث موقف من
الخارجيه الامريكيه تطالب فيها بتحويل هذه
الهدنه من هدنه مؤقته الى دائمه اذا
الخارجيه الامريكيه تدعو الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع للالتزامي بالهدنه وتحويل
هذه الهدنه الى وقف دائما لاطلاق النار
اعود اليك مره جديده سيد عزمي عبد الرازق
سيد عزمي الدكتور خليل اشار الى الاتصالات
التي تجري ومنها اتصالات يقوم بها الجانب
الاسرائيلي وزير الوزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه احدث تقدما مع
الاطراف داخل السودان كيف ينظر الجيش الى
الوساطه الاسرائيليه
وبالطبيعه الحال القوات المسلحه السودانيه
عند علاقه مع اسرائيل وكذلك قوات الدعم
السريعين ده علاقه مع اسرائيل وكله طرف
حاول انه يطور علاقه مختلفه خصوصا بعد
اللقاء الذي تم في عينتي بما بين البرهان
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ولكن عموما
اسرائيل دائما تحاول ان تستثمر في ازمات
السودان ولم تقف اي موقف ايجابي لصالح
السودان يعني طوال السنوات الماضيه يعني
طوال العقود السابقه هي كانت تدعم حركات
التمرد حركه الشعبيه وكذلك حركات دارفور
ولا زالت هي جزء من الازمات وتقوم بتسليح
بعض الحركات المسلحه وربما هي ضايعه الان
في هذه الازمه خصوصا انه نائب غايه قوات
الدعم السريع شقيق حميدتين اللي هو عبد
الرحيم سجل زياره قبل اسابيع من بدايه
الهجوم الى تل ابيب ويبدو بانه على تنسيق
كامل معها وكذلك في نفس الوقت على تنسيق
مع شركه روسيه وبالتالي يعني لا يمكن ان
تكون هنالك دوله
كذلك لماذا التقى برهان
مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
والبرهان كان يظن بانه اسرائيل هي التي
سوف تفتح له باب علاقات جيده مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهي فعلا كانت تدعي ذلك
وبينها هي التي رفعت العقوبات عن السودان
وهي التي رفعت اسم السودان من قائمه الدول
الراعي للارهاب ولكن هذه ليست حقيقه يعني
الحوار مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بدا
منذ ايام البشير والشعب السوداني دفع
فاتوره رفع اسمه السودان من قائمه الدولة
الارهاب يعني اكثر من 200 مليون دولار هي
تكلفه ضحايا
دفعها لشعب السوداني يعني من حر مالي
وبالتالي اسرائيل لم تلعب اي دور هي تحاول
ان تستثمر في هذه الازمه وهي كل ما تريد
اسرائيل هل يمكن ان تنجح سيد عزمي هل يمكن
ان تنجح حيث فشل الاخرون ولا تنسى بان
الخرطوم هي دوله اللاتات الثلاثه
لا اعتقد بان اسرائيل سوف تنجح الان
الوقيع على الارض هي التي سوف تفلي لغتها
الجيش السوداني الان استطاع يعني ان يدمر
كل معسكرات الدعم السريعه الان كل موجود
في كل قواعده كذلك يعني في كل ولايات
السودان لا وجود لقوات الدعم السريع الا
جيوب قليله في الخرطوم الان قوات الدعم
السريع منهكه ومشتته وبلاقي قياده
وبالتالي اعتقد بانه هنالك خيار واحد امام
قوات الدعم السريع هو الاستسلام والدخول
يعني ووقف القتال من جانبه لانه في
النهايه في توصيفه ليست حرب وانما هو
عدوان هنالك قوه مسلحه تمردت على القوات
دعني اسمع من السيده حافظ سيد حافظ كيف
تنظرون الى الوساطه الاسرائيليه ما الذي
يمكن ان تكون عليه ما الذي تطرحه اسرائيل
بتقديرك
يعني قبل الاجابه عن هذا السؤال هناك نقطه
في الاهميه هو ان الذين يريدون الدفاع عن
القوات المسلحه
غير مرتبطه بقيادتها تستطيع ان تقف امامها
لمده اكثر من عشره ايام حتى ان تسترد منها
القياده العامه الجمهوري ولا المطار
الخرطوم ولا يعني حتى اماكن كثيره
القوات المس
لحه
لسيد حافظ
الحكومه المدنيه الاتفاقيات ابغاهم التي
وقعت في ابوظبي لكن العقبه بين الاتفاق
السلام وبين
العقبه بين التوقيع وبين
السودان بين الحكومه المدنيه وبالتالي
يعني كل كل الحكومه وكل المفوضين الذين
اتفقوا مؤخرا عندما جاء وزير الخارجيه
النهائي
بالحكومه بالحكومه المدنيه وبالتالي فيما
يتعلق باتفاق السلامه سيده حافظ كبير ولكن
فيما يتعلق بوقف المواجهات حاليا والمضيق
قدما في وقف دائم لاطلاق النار الدوري
الذي تلعبه اسرائيل وحدود هذا الدور
هنا سؤالي
ن اعمق واطول مع المؤسس العسكريه مختلف
الجيش عندما زار
الجيش
حينها
متر لكن عامه
هو مرتبط يعني رؤيه رؤيه
اسرائيل
وعلى اهميه التوقيع على الاتفاق وكذلك على
اهميه الاصدار في المنطقه هذا هو ما يدفع
اسرائيل التدخل اعتقد انه الذي
تفعله اسرائيل من خلال علاقته مع الطرفين
هي يعني اخذ الطرفين للقاعه التفاوض
ومن ثم ليس هناك
ممكن ان تختلف عن ما كان يعني متفق عليه
سابقا الحكومه المدنيه خروج المؤثره
العسكريه من السياسه وكذلك يعني المضي نحو
تاسيس
وتكويل سلطه يعني شرعيه فوريه لا اعتقد ان
الاسلام سيقبلون لكن الطريقه التي
الاجراءات والمجموعه
الانتصار لموظف
ان الطرفين سيد حافظ كبير يقومان بذلك
ساعود اليك ولكن دعني اسمع من الدكتور
خليل العنان الدكتور خليل الجانب الامريكي
يقول بانه سيددرس الاقتراحات الاسرائيليه
هل هنالك تنسيق امريكي اسرائيلي ام ان
يعني اسرائيل تسبق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في هذا الاطار
متقدمه عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
نعم متقدمه جدا استاذه فداء الموضوع ليس
فقط تنسيق هناك التعاويل امريكا كبير جدا
على اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بالازمه السودانيه
ايضا لابد ان نضع الاطار المبادره
الاسرائيليه في اطار امرين رئيسيين الامر
رمزي اسرائيل تصطاد في الماء العاكر تحاول
ان تستغلها من اجل طرح نفسها باعتبارها
بسيط بين الاطراف المتصارعه المتحاربه
راينا ذلك في الصراع الروسي الاوكراني عند
مقترحه تسليم المبادره لحل الصراع طبعا لم
تسفر عن شيء الان في اطار الازمه
السودانيه طبعا هناك حضور اسرائيلي قوي
جدا اسرائيل مخترقه النخب العسكريه
السودانيه على مدار اخر اربع سنوات على
الاقل هناك امثله كثيره جدا ذكر بعضها
الضيف قبل قليل من الخرطوم هناك علاقات
مستمره وقويه جدا بين حمدتي وبين ضباط
الاسرائيلي زيارات قام بها لاسرائيل سرا
وقام بزيارات اخرى قام الاسرائيلي والتقوى
حميد حماتي في السودان هناك علاقات ما بين
البرهان كما تفضل الشرطي في اللقاء الشرق
بينهما 2020 في اوغندا عن طريق الامارات
قبل حوالي عام من الان هناك حديث او تقرير
حول قيام اسرائيل بمد حمد باجهزه تجسس من
خلال شركه اسرائيليه في اليونان كدعم
اسرائيلي استخبارات وامني لحميدتي كما
تفضل قليل اللي هو عبد الرحيم دجله نائب
رئيس قوات الدعم السريع نائب حميد بمعنى
اخوه قمر زياره الاسرائيلي قبل الانقلاب
على على الاتفاق الشرقي مع المدنيين في
اكتوبر 2021 في نفس الوقت هناك علاقات ما
بين البرهان وبين اسرائيل وبالتالي هناك
التعويل الامريكي على اسرائيل كي تقوم
بدور في الضغط على الاطراف المتحاربه
واعتقد نحن ازاء محاوله اسرائيليه اشتغل
هذه الازمه من اجل الظهور مصدر الوسيط في
هذه الصراع ايضا على اطراف الاخرى الطرف
الطرفين المهمين فدى الاطار الاقليميين
الامارات من جهه ومصر من جهه اخرى لمحمدتي
دعم البرهان وبالتالي هناك تعاون اسرائيل
على استغلال نفوس لدى الامارات ومصر من
اجل الدفع باتجاه نوع من الحل قد يكون
الدائم لهذا الصراع هل تنجح في ذلك ام لا
هذا سؤال الوقت يجب ان ننتظر حتى نرى مصر
عنه هذا التحرك الاسرائيلي طيب اعود مره
جديده الى السيده عزمي سيده عزمي انت لم
تكن متفائلا بهذه الهدنه في بدايه هذا
اللقاء ما هي السيناريودات السيناريوهات
المتوقعه في المرحله المقبله مع خروج
الدبلوماسيين والرعايه الاجانب من السودان
هل نحن مقبلون على توسع هذه المواجهات
وطبعا ليس عدم تفاعل ولكن واقعي يعني
الهدنه لم تصمد يعني الخلاء في الساعات
الاولى هنالك بيان للمؤسسه العسكريه ذكرت
بان قوات الدعم السريع خلقت الهدنه بل
يعني هي ما زالت يعني تحتل المرافق الصحيه
متواجده في الاحياء اخرجت اسر من بيوتها
واحتلت تلك البيوت كذلك الان هي موجوده في
مصفاه الجيل ما علاقه مصفاه الجيل بالتحول
الديمقراطي وفقا للشعارات التي ترفعها
وبالتالي يعني من الصور مكان في ظل هذا
هذا المشهد الفوضوي او عدم الاحتراف
بهزيمه قوات الدعم السريع من قبلها ان
تصمد اي هدى خصوصا بانه قائدها لا يقبل اي
هزيمه وبالتالي هو يستعجل النصر السريع
بخلاف القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي يبدو
بانها ليست مستعجله الى اي نصر الان طبعا
المعروف بانه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اجت كل رعاياها كذلك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
يمكن ان تراقب وقف اطلاق النار او او تحدد
من هو الطرف اطلق النار سوى البيانات
المتاحه الان في في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وفي الاساطير وبالتالي يعني لا
يوجد الان اي شخص لديه قدر على فرد هدنه
على الاطراف منطقه القتال هو الذي يفرض
نفسه
الفكره سيد عزمي في تدمير البنيه التحتيه
لغات الدعم السريع لدي فقط اقل من دقيقتين
سيد عزمي وكف الله المؤمنين شر القتال
اسمع من السيد حافظ سيد حافظ الى اين تتجه
الامور في السودان
يعني بعد ان فشل منطق القوه هناك اتجاه
واحد يمكن اتجاه نحوه وهو الحوار السياسي
الذي يعني انقطع بسبب محاولات الاتحاد
التيار الذي ذكرته كذلك هناك منطق في
الارض هو الذي يضمن الهدنه هو منطقه القوه
الذي
يفشل المخاطبات الاخرى وبالتالي ليس هناك
من ضام لا دولي ولا داخلي حتى سوى القوه
التي تحمل الجميع وتجبر الاطراف او تجبر
الطرف الذي لا يريد التفاوض ان يتفاوض
وتجبره ايضا على المضيء في العمل السياسي
وتثبت ايضا من خلال التجاره والسابقه لا
طريق سوى الطريقه العمليه السياسيه التي
يرفضها ويحاول التملص عنها عبر الحرب تاره
وعبر التحكم بان الاطراف لا تمثل كل
السودان لكنها في الاخر ليس هناك سبيل
جديد سوى سوى المواصله في هذا الاتجاه
وهذا ما ذكرته طاهر الدمعه منذ اليوم
الاول دكتوره خليل العنان من الواضح ان
تبادل الاته امات مستمر هل من افاق لهذه
المبادرات التي والاتصالات التي تجري في
ظلما نراه ونسمعه
الامر توقف على مدى استجابه الطرفين
الداخلي لهذا الموضوع ايضا يتوقف الامر
على مدى الظروف في المحليه والاقليميه
والدوليه في هذا الاطار حتى هذه اللحظه
كما قلت في بدايه الحلقه هناك شروط وهناك
متطلبات للنجاح اي مبادره سياسيه اولا
الامر يتعلق هل هذه مبادره تطرح حلول
جذريه للازمه الحاليه كما قلت نحن على
السلطه بعد طرفين دخل فيما يبدو في معادله
صفريه لدى الصراع الامر الثاني متعلق بمدى
وجود ادوات وان يبحث اي مبادره بمعنى اخر
ادوات للضغط كما قلت منطق العصا والجزره
الامر الثالث وجود اتفاق اقليمي ودولي
وعلى اقل نوع من الموافقه الدوليه على حل
الازمه الحاليه في السودان خليل العنانيه
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والبحث بالمركز العربي في واشنطن شكرا لك
وشكر موصول لحافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من الخرطوم وايضا السيده عزمي عبد
الرازق الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء والتغطيه مستمره
[موسيقى]